hi welcome
I should apologize for the fact
I only learned I was doing this at about
two o'clock yesterday so it's pretty
much a rerun of last year and I might
not be entirely practiced though I do
talk about this stuff a lot so hopefully
it'll be okay
the flights include some fairly small
text that you might find difficult to
read there is a URL on here which claims
you can get the slides and you will be
able to do that but not at this moment
but if you and I'll read it out because
it's tiny but if you go to the same
thing with 2017 in it you can get last
year's and there are only two slides
that are different so so the URL is TDD
eight dot info slash PDF / T DDA -
tutorial
- high data - London - and then for last
year's 2017 dot PDF so if you're
struggling to read these those might
help if you haven't already done it and
you do want to follow along there are
there are exercises and exercises there
are there are things to do during the
session you should install the TDD a
library which you can get from PI P I
with pip install TDD a or you can get it
from github if you prefer from the TDD a
account from the library is called
TDD a so do interrupt if I'm not clear
which will almost certainly be the case
the whole thing's supposed to be very
informal so today we're talking about
test-driven data analysis and I'm going
to start off by trying to motivate that
for you and it's as much of a surprise
to you how it's going to start as it is
to me I mean surprises to me as to you
right so the idea yes of course it's
called it's called test-driven data
analysis taking its inspiration from
test-driven development and the idea is
that we need to take the ideas of
testing from test-driven development
this idea that before you write code
your write tests and then you run the
tests and they
fail and then you correct the tasks by
implementing code we need to take that
idea and inject a bit more of that idea
if trying to make software correct into
the into into data analysis where
there's typically a lot less testing in
my experience certainly a lot less
systematic testing and one of the
interesting challenges with testing data
analysis as opposed to testing software
is I think it's a lot harder because
mostly with software with many kinds of
software anyway we kind of know when the
answers right it's kind of obvious you
know it's it's does it crash it's does
the interface do the right thing sure
you know whether there's weather whether
it's maths involved things can go wrong
but it tends to be more obvious whether
things are working
whereas with analysis we have to be
concerned not only with is is the
software or the implementation of our
analytical process in whatever set of
tools were using working we also have to
be concerned with the meaningfulness of
the analysis is it producing answers
that are going to be interpreted
correctly we have to be worried about
whether the input data is valid because
we all know garbage in garbage out but
it's not really good enough for us as
data scientists to say well you know you
feed bad data and it's not my
responsibility I think it kind of is our
responsibility and we have to be
responsible for helping people to
interpret correctly so it's it's with
all those things in mind that we've
developed this idea of test driven data
analysis and I guess the way we think
about this is that almost always these
days
there's some kind of a development phase
where we when you're developing analysis
you always work in the context of a data
set you're almost you're almost never
doing it without data and inevitably the
data that you use to develop the process
effects the way that the way that you
develop the algorithms or the processes
and there are lots of things that can go
wrong during that development phase the
first of which is you know you have to
choose how you're going to tackle your
problem and you can fail to understand
all sorts of things you can fail to
understand the data correctly you can
fail to understand the problem domain or
you can have an insufficiently good
understanding of the algorithms and what
the requirements those algorithms the
statistical law
or any other aspect of them and when
those things go wrong we like to
classify things and we call those kinds
of errors errors of interpretation so
things can go wrong there and then you
have to implement your process which you
know in our case might be a question of
writing Python code but it might just be
a question of putting something together
in Excel or using R or SAS or whatever
and unfortunately some of us are capable
of making errors at that stage too
traditionally those obviously are known
as bugs but we call them errors of
interpretation just to keep the error of
the thing going and I guess the idea is
if you get through both of those stages
without making mistakes then you get
your initial success and 20 years ago
that was pretty much what what people
who weren't then called data scientist
have to do but now it's typically worse
than that because now when we develop
analysis we want to put it into some
kind of operation we don't want to just
run it as a one-off thing on on one
particular set of numbers we want to
have something that we can apply again
and even if we don't believe that when
we're developing it almost always after
we've finished it one of the following
things happens either someone tells us
that data you analyzed yeah that was the
wrong data could you just do it again on
on the corrected data or you know your
boss comes over and says yeah that thing
I said could you just do a quick and
dirty woonsocket could you just do it
again on this month's data because it
was really great so you almost always
end up with this this neat to be able to
use whatever you developed on a new set
of data which is potentially its own
challenge when you do that there's a
whole new set of opportunities for
things to go wrong because now you have
to run the analytical process and it's
possible to use the software incorrectly
to type the wrong options to use the
wrong version of the software to fail to
understand that it's a Python 3 not a
Python 2 package or a Python 2 not a
Python 3 package or that it you know
whatever and when the call goes there is
a process when things go wrong there
perhaps the subtlest one is that as I
emphasized it's it's almost impossible
to develop most analytical processes
without making assumptions about the
data and those and those assumptions
shape our analysis quite strongly but
quite often those assumption
turn out not to be true for all the data
that we ever put through the system and
so sometimes even when it produces
numerically correct results that are
executing the algorithm that you wanted
the assumptions that you had implicitly
made in producing the algorithm turn out
to invalidate the at least the
interpretation of the answers and when
that happens we call that an error of
applicability and the final thing of
course is even if we don't make any
mistakes anywhere along the way we can
still misinterpret the results I used to
Sharon off when I was doing an office
with a guy who was a great one for
staring at a graph and saying yeah I can
see why it's like that and I say to him
you ever
you've got the graph upside down and it
turned upside down and say yeah I can
see why it's like that it's very easy to
get seduced by the beautiful output that
we produce from computers and things
because it's all beautifully formatted
and nicely colored and very plausible
and exactly what we expected that it's
right but it's not true so probably your
thing here thinking I don't make any of
these kinds of mistakes I'm better than
that and you probably are but it's it's
quite sobering if you do buy into this
sort of framework at all oh sorry the
other thing that happens of course is
you go around this this last bit of it
lots of time speeding more data sets in
yeah I told you I was out of practice
with it
it's quite sobering to just put some
numbers on it and think you know I've
put what I think are quite optimistic
numbers on for how likely we are to go
wrong so I'm saying there's only a 20%
chance we'll will misunderstand
something fundamental in the approach
that we're taking there's only a 30%
chance that there'll be bugs in our
software which i think is fantastically
obviously now you know I'm talking about
important bugs you're not ones that you
know cause a line break in the wrong
place but things that cause the wrong
answer to be produced I'm assuming
there's only a 10% chance that will
screw it up when we run the software
bearing in mind that it might not even
be us it might be someone else on the
software a 20% chance that the data will
have changed in such a way that it's no
longer what we assumed when we develop
the thing and only a 10% chance that
will misinterpret the results and if all
of that's true
the first time you run the process you
have a 36% charm
of getting the right answer now you know
maybe you think all these numbers are
incredibly pessimistic put your own
numbers it it'll still be scary and of
course the really good thing is every
time you go around this process you get
a chance to screw up again so so there's
a lot that can go wrong so what we're
really going to talk about today is
desktop and data analysis which is both
a methodology a way of thinking about
how we do data analysis data science
machine learning whatever you want to
call it and also in the form of the open
source TDD a library a set of software
that can help you with this there's
there's a set of proprietary extensions
we have as well but I'm not really going
to talk about those and there are sort
of two two-and-a-half main ideas in
tester and data analysis we're going to
do examples and exercises on both parts
we're going to start with what we call
reference tests which are maybe the less
exciting part but definitely an
important part and then we're going to
move on to talk about automatic
constraint discovery and verification so
reference tests are kind of just like
the tests that hopefully we're all used
to writing in in ordinary software
development so you know you can compare
those two particularly system or
integration tests rather than unit tests
they certainly apply to the equivalent
of unit testing too but I'm in the
minority of people who thinks that the
integration tests the system tests in
all in all contexts are more important
than the unit test which of course unit
tests are important but I dislike the
way everyone focuses on not everyone a
lot of people focus on unit testing and
don't really bother with system testing
but particularly for analysis I think
it's testing the whole system that's
fundamentally important so it's support
for helping writing tests that are
appropriate to data analysis where and
what I what I would claim is that the
usual way we're taught to do test-driven
development is hard for data analysis
because the usual thing we're told is
first write the test with the correct
answer then run the code a certain bit
well then run the test and obviously
we'll fail because we don't have any
and then implement the code to make the
test pass the trouble is most of the
outputs that we generate in Daytona lose
a lot of them are things that we can't
compute by hand so unless we have
another package that already does it we
simply don't have the option of you know
I'll just draw the graph by hand and
check that it that it that it comes out
correctly or I'll just compute these two
million numbers by hand and so we kind
of have to do it backwards and there are
another one of the things that's that's
different is very often the answers are
not the same every single time and I'm
not primarily talking about numerical
instability or the fact that we use
random numbers I'm talking about even
things like because they have a date in
that changes or because you use
matplotlib and it turns out and that
plotly abuses random labels all over the
place and reorders things because it
pulls them out of dictionaries and all
sorts of stuff that just mean the actual
generated result isn't identical sort of
syntactically to the one that you might
have saved even if it's semantically
identical so so the first part is about
providing what we call reference test
support support for writing tests that
are useful for data analysis and then
the second part is all about automatic
constraint discovery and verifications
so the idea there is that when we're
doing data analysis we have data at all
stages we have input data we have
typically intermediate results and we
have output results and all of those are
things we should want to test we should
want to check that at the very least the
data we develop the process with
produces the same answer when we run it
a second time in a third time and we and
we potentially want to check the input
data we want to check the intermediate
results and we want to check the output
results and a really powerful way of
doing that is using constraints and we
can write those constraints by hand but
we can also get the software to find
suitable constraints for us from
examples and that's what probably the
bigger part of this morning will be
about so any questions before we move on
to start actually looking at stuff I can
hardly see you because I'm kind of
blinded by these lights but it's much a
shout if there is anything
and take it though we're good so
hopefully you've all either done a pip
install TDD a or a get clone of the
repository and then a Python setup I
install the library is Python 2 and
Python 3 compliant obviously you all
know that you should be on Python 3 by
now even if you really don't want to be
but it should work either way the
library
I believe runs on all platforms it's
true that we run it on Windows rather
less often than on the other platforms
but we have done so and last time we did
it it did work and it's compatible with
both unit tests and PI tests so you can
use whichever you prefer it's MIT
license there is documentation standard
Sphinx documentation and you can see it
no yeah not at that URL at all its own
read the docs now isn't it it's at right
so I will I will try and room to crack
this but it's a TDD a dot read the docs
dot IO not a Python host because
obviously we've moved over to warehouse
since last year and there is a quick
reference sheet that's only slightly out
of date now that URL there I'll try and
update that as well apologies for the
fact this is I know I know some of this
is too small to read so reference tests
I've probably talked about this so the
idea is our analyst processes whatever
that computes something or produces a
graph or gives us a go/no-go or tells
our chap what what to do or whatever it
takes inputs in the form of you know the
data and parameters typically and it
generates some kind of outputs and the
minimum idea for a reference does the
idea of a reference ask really and if
you're not familiar with testing don't
worry about it you can you can just
start from here the idea is if you do
nothing else at the very least record
the inputs that you used when you
develop the process capture the process
preferably in an executable form where
you just have to you know conceptually
push a button type make do some simple
command to run the thing and capture the
outputs that you produced so that you
can check at some future point when you
come back
to it that a it still runs and be
hopefully that it produces the same
answer and so the second idea is not
only should you be able to look at the
answer and see whether it's the same but
ideally there should be some kind of an
automated way of checking that the
results the same you know the equivalent
of a diff or a compare or whatever for
whatever your outputs are and that's
what we try to help with with reference
tests it's quite closely related to the
idea of reproducible research which you
may have come across in the academic
community reproducible research is it's
more the idea of using other people to
check that your stuffs right by making
your data and your code available for
other people to look at one of the nice
things about the reference testing
approach is that even if no one else
ever looks at your code you can still
get benefit from it because you yourself
benefit over time from from what you've
done now one of the things that
sometimes people say it at this point is
you know if I write my code and I put it
there and I leave it and my data stays
the same then I run it again later
surely it's going to produce the same
answer what could possibly go wrong
at which point hopefully half of you
burst into laughter because you've all
experienced the fact that you wouldn't
believe the things that can go wrong
whether it's you know that your
operating system decides to do an auto
update or you upgrade your Python or you
upgrade one of the libraries or what a
helpful co-worker upgrade something on
your system you know and that's before
actually you did edit it you just made a
little tweak that couldn't possibly
break anything but turns out it's quite
how to make tweaks that can't possibly
break anything or you get bit rot and
the date has changed or you're not
running the version of the code you
thought you were or there are so many
things that can go wrong that I
guarantee if you do this you'll find
quite a lot of the time when you run the
test it won't pass another time so this
is this is valuable even if you never
change anything but in fact you will
change things because when you know your
boss your client whatever says could you
just run that thing again on the updated
data it will turn out that that data has
a different format has a different
distribution has whatever and things
won't be the same and then your your
your make an adjustment to handle the
new date format or the extra column or
whatever it is and that will break your
original
without your realizing it so so what's
in the reference test library there are
things for comparing an actual string
that you've got in memory or in file one
that you've produced from your code with
some expected string that you've stored
away in writing file there is the
ability to exclude lines with particular
sub strings like a date or a version
number or something like that that you
can specify either as literal or as a
regular expression there's the ability
to there are sort of hooks that allow
you to put functions in to pre-process
output so if there are things that you
know are going to vary that you don't
care about you can take them out by hand
by hand in code by writing a function
that manipulates the thing before it
tests it it can write the actual string
produced to a file when it's different
so that if it turns out something's
changed you're not trying to compare
something on the screen with something
that's in a file it's written a file for
you that you can then use diff or open
there for visual dip or whatever to to
understand what's going on it will tell
you what the difficulty
execute to do that is it will allow you
to check multiple files on a single test
and report all the failures rather than
falling over at the first one and if you
ever do that thing you're not supposed
to do but we all do where you loop over
a whole lot of test cases and a single
test particularly if there's lots of
expensive set up and the other thing it
can do which turns out to be super
useful but easy to abuse is if if you do
find that the result has changed but the
reason the result has changed is either
that some formatting things change that
doesn't matter but it's the new way of
doing things or it's changed because
your original test result was wrong when
you've now fixed it it will
automatically update it can
automatically when you tell it to update
the reference results that it's
comparing things to with the existing
ones now obviously if every time a test
fails you tell it just just write the
new the new results to the reference
output then you'll get no value out of
the system but if you carefully check
them by hand and only tell it to rewrite
the results when you've really hand on
heart promise you've checked that
nuances are actually better than the old
answers then this can be tremendously
powerful so there's a set of methods
that are very much like the unit test
methods in the case of the unit test
support so you can say self dot search
string correct and you can give it a
string that the string that you want to
test and the path qualifier with file in
it that's got the the expected string
you can directly check two files if
you're generating files you can check
sets of files and all dot dots indicate
there are lots of extra grams you can
put in to say do you want to strip the
strings beforehand do you want to assign
the other and that makes it sound like
we're just talking about strings but
we're not there are things for checking
data frames there are things for
checking a numbers there all sorts of
things which I can't remember whether we
talked about later
but I mean this is the point where you
get to do some work so if you if you
have the library
it comes with examples so if you go
somewhere you don't mind creating some
directories and then you type tgd a
examples it should copy three sets it
should create three direct sub
directories for you for the different
kinds of tests we'll be doing today and
the ones we're interested in first of
all are in reference test examples so
hopefully if you do something like CD /
toneport riddles Ashton or wherever you
want to put things TDA examples and then
go into that reference test examples you
should find two files string result dot
HTML and file result dot HTML which you
can look at they're just HTML files so
you can you can open them in a browser
or you can if you have a sub person who
likes reading HTML you can read it and
then if you are not philosophically
committed to PI test you can go into the
unit test subdirectory and run Python
tests using reference desk a spy and
hopefully the testers will pass and then
we'll have a look at what it was doing
or if you're more a PI test kind of a
person
my test director and it's like PI test
so I'll give you all along to do that so
what actually maybe I'll do the first
bit of that right and then in reference
I think now we are so if we look at the
file result
it's that incredibly exciting webpage
fare and if we look at the string result
it's that similarly super exciting
webpage so and what I claimed is that if
you run all that I say that if you run
tests using reference test case in the
unit test subdirectory there isn't a
unit a subdirectory excellent
then everything passes five tests pass
has everyone who wants to succeeded in
doing that all very quiet I'm gonna take
that as a yes so the interesting thing
about this is that the result that this
produced was not identical so let's have
a look at let's have a look at tests
Union using reference testify so it's
got some of the usual boilerplate stuff
at the top for handling Python 2 in
Python 3
and it's got various sets of this first
one unless a data frame one example
string generation so that's what we're
looking at I think
so we have a function that generates the
string the HTML page in memory together
with string result that HTML and that
string result the HTML the things set up
so that it knows that should be in that
reference test subdirectory there's a
we're telling it to ignore the sub
strings copyright and version because
there's copyright line that changes each
time we update the library and version
number that changes each time we update
the library and they're different and
then we've got a sort of file example as
well where now we're generating this so
if I compare god you can tell I can't
remember how to do this if I compare
I can pass something or other generated
us
oh maybe are maybe you're supposed to
run generators first
I wonder where it's generated there is a
lot it's all effects folks it's not
doing that at all
generate file and write it to HTML HTML
was HTML to pass when I was pass no pass
score from reference test it probably
cleans itself up
I'm out path is not there
oh it's writing it to tumped is the
point right so here's the good thing to
do here's the good things to edit the
generator to change what it produces yes
of course edit generator so if you take
that generator code
yes this is the thing to do so the HTML
generated just directly from that big
multi-line string literal if you edit
that code and change say the page title
or the h1 or something like that then
obviously you'll get a different result
and I should start failing but if you
edit something like the version string
in there that shouldn't cause the test
to fail so that's why we suggested you
first try changing that 2016 copyright
notices to say 2018 check the result
still pass and then change you know the
title or something something else and
now the test should fail and it will
give you the thing sorry in my defense I
didn't know I was doing this tool
yesterday and I would have tried it and
so I'm gonna do that while you're
hopefully doing it yourself and a tiny
little window that you can't read
so I'm first of all going to change for
that 2016 to 2018 and everything should
still be fine everything still passes
but when I change anything more
meaningful
we got a failure and it gives us the
diff command that we need to see the
failure which we can run and so we see
the copyright and versions are different
but that's okay that the test was told
to ignore that but we can also see the
KKK on the line and obviously if we do
something a nice like an open diff or
whatever your visual difficult on
whatever platform you're using is so the
same thing but just out open we see
visually rather more clearly what's
changed
okay would anyone like more time to play
with that or shall we press on so that's
that's the general concept with
reference testing let's find out what
the slides say we're doing next and
we'll decide whether we want to do that
or they want to move on to constraints
oh look at that there are instructions
modified generators dot pi there you go
run everything again see a failure check
the results yes all that stuff exactly
[Music]
yep so that's fine so then the other
sorts of things that are in the
reference test library as well as things
for checking strings there's something
to check a data frame where you can
specify whether you want to check all
the columns or just particular columns
you can specify numerical precision you
can probably specify a bunch of other
things but I can't remember you can
specify a different way you like
comparing data frames you can specify a
difficult for doing that it can check
CSV files as well as data frames
provided that the CSV files are readable
by pandas CSV reader with the sensible
options that we'll talk about later that
we tend to pass to that you can choose
whether you care about the types of the
column so one of the things any of you
who use pandas will know is that it's
got a fairly flexible attitude toward
types and if you for example take an
integer column and throw a novel into it
suddenly you might find it's not quite
such an integer column anymore it's
become a real column and all that kind
of stuff you can tell the library
whether you care about that stuff you
can tell the library whether you care
about the order of columns in a data
frame you can choose to ignore the
actual data in particular columns you
can choose the precision for your
floating-point comparisons and again you
can get it to automatically rewrite
files if you like so all of that stuff
is in there I don't think we have
exercises for all of that but you can
certainly play
that so bunch methods
and again I'm showing the unit test ones
there are the obvious PI test
equivalents of these as well without the
selves so for asserting that CSV files
correct or a bunch of CSV files correct
or a data frames correct or a bunch of
data frame correct what data frames
equal give us interesting Oh
so the first one is for checking a data
frame against a CSV file and second
one's for checking a data frame against
another data frame that you have in
memory so oh there isn't exercise for
that oh well let's do like itself let's
try the data frame exercise so
apparently there yes so say me oh no
it's that has the same exercise the
point is we can look at the data frame
being generated with this two line
program oh let's do that
I'm glad I wrote all the stuff down so
let's try running that and see what it
does
so that's the data frame it's generating
okay so run the tests we've already done
that modify data frames dot pi to change
the division the precision from three to
two okay well that's for everything up
whatnot so presumably that's in data
frames dot pi that's presumably a
precision somewhere they all change
that's two and so now we get two digits
and that s column as opposed to three
and now if we run the test we got a
failure which we could look at but
presumably I'm imagining there's gonna
be a punch line if we tell it to
[Music]
right oh and so the idea here is lecture
you're rewriting output yes if we say
this is actually the result we want now
we want to you know we've changed my
mind and two decimal places is is the
answer that we want as our reference
what we can do is run the tests again
but now say either minus capital W if
you're lazy like me or if you're not a
lazy person you can say minus minus
right all and that will cause it to
regenerate all the reference test
results for us and therefore if I run
the tests again without the right or
they pass again because we've updated
the reference results so sorry that was
all slightly slightly mad because I
don't know what I'm doing but hopefully
that all makes sense and you'll find it
useful one very cool capability we've
added recently I guess the thing that
you're talked when you learn testing is
that your test should take about a
nanosecond to run so that you can run
more time we find that quite often our
test Suites take several nanoseconds to
run sometimes even minutes or hours to
run depending on what we're doing and
again in the context of concentrating
more integration and system testing and
on generating large complex analytical
results even if you scale down the data
that's often quite hard to avoid so it
becomes particularly useful to be able
to run individual tests or individual
subsets of tests and you can obviou that
by putting the test name on the command
line or you know my favorite technique
of sticking an A in front of the test
method so that he doesn't get picked up
but we have a nice capability now in the
very latest version of the TDD a library
which is not 0.5 point 12 and if you
picked it up as an or point 5 point 11
yesterday it's it's not there under this
name yet but if you update it will be we
have this very nice ability to tag tests
and what that means is that if you run
with either minus 1 or minus tagged on
the - - tagged
the command line it will run only the
tests that are tagged and what we mean
by tagging is if you import tag from the
same place as reference test case if you
if you use the decorator apt tag in
front of either a test or a test class
that will tag that class when you run
with minus one it will only run the tag
tests or the tests in tag classes and if
you what happens if you have a lot of
test files with that is you find you now
don't know where the tag ones are so to
avoid you having to grep you can also
say minus zero or minus is tagged and it
will tell you which of your classes in
which of your files are currently tied
these so you can go and update them and
remove them and that sounds like a
really stupid tiny bit of functionality
but it saves hours and hours and hours
if you use this stuff we've had a very
similar capability in our commercial
software for years in a slightly
slightly less elegant form actually and
we use it absolutely all the time it's
particularly good when you're developing
some new pieces of functionality in
context and it's got a big test suite
and you just want to keep running one
test over and over again surprising how
simple these things how powerful these
simple things can be okay
any questions before we move on to talk
about constraints
yes
we've been doing this stuff so long that
we have our own our analytical software
that has the same sort of structure as a
data frame that we developed about ten
years ago and with that we're still
using so conceptually we're doing very
similar stuff we just have a version
that doesn't use literally a panda's
data frame it uses a mirror data set
which is sort of our equivalent of that
kind of thing and we use that absolutely
all the time both when we're developing
the software so whenever we make any
change that software we're constantly
checking that we haven't broken any of
our existing functionality but also when
we're doing anything for clients we
really are quite religious about about
doing this stuff we I mean we don't
follow the the test dogma in the Senate
so of writing a test first because the
DEF explain we typically can't do that
because we we can't generate the results
into until we've we've written the code
to do it but we really do pretty much as
soon as we've got something that we
think is working we capture the result
we've build it into a test and then we
keep running that and we actually have
it running on continuous integration
service so that twice a day the whole
test suite for all of our client
projects from the data hasn't expired
yet but during the whole course of a
project we're running the tests as we
build up the thing as we go and you know
I mean the particular kinds of projects
we're doing that with we've done a lot
of work with Skyscanner over recent
years on travel so we've been doing
things like modeling the surcharges that
their partners put on flights we've been
building anti-gaming systems for them
we've been we've been looking at their
complaints and building reporting
systems for their complaints we do
credit scoring works or the same thing
again checking that given a historical
file the even particular models train
the right way and more particularly
models that we've already built are
producing the right results that we
expect and that when we update the model
you know we update the reference results
for that and check
so we're doing it absolutely all the
time
even when we're not doing it our
integration servers are doing it for us
so help
yeah if you run it with - couple W or -
manage right all it will generate it for
you
yes I think we might generate I think we
might regard that as as just a stage to
far in terms that we're trying quite
hard to get the balance right between
making it easy easy for it to take the
work out of generating stuff when you
know that you want it to do that but not
making it so easy that you just
constantly keep creating wrong results
because to start with the first time you
generate it it almost certainly won't be
right and I feel like if you just
generated it as the reference result
that I feel like that might discourage
you from going and actually checking it
by hand whereas the process I can't
emphasize enough none of this stuff
means you don't have to check it by hand
on on contrary you absolutely have to
check that the stuff really is it is the
right answer it is true that even in
advance of knowing that it's the right
answer it's useful to know that it's the
same answer because you know
unintentionally stochastic software is
not great
although although there's sort of this
idea that you should never you should
never test floats exactly because you
know their floats they're sort of
arbitrarily true
on any given platform you should get
identical results when you run the same
code even when it's generating floating
point answers as long as you fix any
seeds if you're using random number
generators and I've been quite surprised
over the years now that everything
standard are virtually everything
standardized on I Triple E floating
point notation
I've even implemented things like in
Python - in Python 3 in Postgres and got
identical answers to full full precision
now in the case of databases obviously
you have lots of choices below to fire a
personation but if you choose the right
one you can certainly do like 10 decimal
places of precision and things work you
can go much further than a lot of people
think you can go without anything
changing and as I say for for a
particular code running on a particular
computer it should definitely produce
identical results with identical inputs
in the absence of stochastic stuff ok
let's move on and talk about constraints
yeah
that's an interesting question the
question if people couldn't hear it was
what if something else depends on that
reference output as well is there a way
of telling it not to overwrite it I
suppose I think the real answer is no I
mean the way of telling it not to
overwrite it is not to use the minus W
or minus right all Flags to tell it to
overwrite it but no there's not a way of
there's not there's nothing in the
library to understand dependencies and
understand that you shouldn't just
update a particular reference result or
whatever that someone you would have to
manage externally but it's an
interesting thought okay let's talk
about constraints so here's a
controversial statement very commonly
data analysis uses data tables
particularly if you're not doing tax
mining you know data frames or whatever
as inputs as outputs and as
intermediates and there are almost
always things we know what to be true
about this data we might not always make
them explicit but there are almost
always things we know and in principle
we could write down all these
expectations as constraints and check
that they're satisfied that the inputs
satisfy what they ought to satisfy that
the outputs satisfy things we ought to
they ought to satisfy and so on but life
is too short and even if life weren't
too short you know we're human we're not
very good at writing down correct
answers ahead of things notwithstanding
the unit testing dogma so the big idea
with this constraint generation stuff is
since we're not very good at it and
since it's really boring since computers
are really good at boring things that
we're not very good at why don't we get
the computer to generate constraints for
us and then we can verify against those
constraints and if it generates the
wrong constraints at least we get a
starting point that we can edit and
typically in my experience people are
much happier to spot mistakes in
something an edited by hand than to be
presented with an empty editor and you
know not yourself out types and JSON
it's it's really good as long as you
remember the commas and
and stuff so what are some examples of
constrained as well you know if you've
got ages of human beings they probably
shouldn't be negative and they probably
shouldn't be bigger than 150 or maybe
even ten or something probably ages
ought to be integers or at least numbers
if you've got a master table with
customer IDs in it then probably those
shouldn't be null and probably if it's a
master table they shouldn't be repeated
if you've got a credit card number it
probably ought to have sixteen digits
it'd be nice if it allowed spaces but
apparently that's beyond the wit of
programmers so so we don't allow those
if you're a biologist and you're looking
at DNA then probably the bases ought to
be mostly C gsa's and T's and so forth
dates yeah all the usual stuff in
principle even looking at distributions
and things we've got human heights you
probably have some idea what the range
of those heights ought to be and what
they look like so there are constraints
that you can put on individual values
and individual columns there are also
constraints that operate more at data
set level so maybe your data frame or
your data set or your database table or
whatever has to include particular
columns maybe it has to have a
particular number of Records
maybe fields are supposed to be tagged
or indicated in some way maybe it's
supposed to be sorted in some way like
data sending or whatever and there also
might the constraints between fields so
a very common one if you have start
dates and end dates for example in many
cases it's nice if the start date isn't
after the end date but in real data
obviously it often is if you have if you
have columns representing force and math
and mass and acceleration then probably
there ought to be a newtonian sort of
relationship between between them given
that F equals MA if you've got a bunch
of favorites and only one of them is
allowed to be one then if you some of
them you should you should get one and
so forth so there are lots of things we
could specify but that are a bit painful
for us to do by hand the kinds of
constraints that the TDD a library
understand
our min and Max constraints new in the
case of strings min and max length
constraints sine constraints separately
from min and Max from strings so the
idea there is it's all very well you can
specify a min and maximum range and
obviously that implicitly says whether
it's R to be positive but it's sort of a
more significant change if something
that was always positive previously
turns negative so we redundantly store
constraints about sign or camera done
and they store constraints about sign we
can specify whether fields are allowed
to be null in fact we can specify the
maximum number of nulls allowed on the
field but usually that's either 0 or
unspecified we can specify that a fields
not allowed to have duplicates if it's
not and the most powerful thing is we
can also well particularly in terms of
generation is we can also specify one or
more regular expressions that string
fields is supposed to represent and when
we come to automatically generating them
we can automatically generate regular
expressions from examples which is why I
talked about kind of two and a half bits
of functionality in the light because
that's sufficiently different that it's
useful even if you're not using the rest
of the stuff and we call that
functionality racks play so those of you
who have laptops and are following along
you should already have the examples if
you go to the constraints examples
rather than the reference test examples
that we were in before oh yes we're
working with the periodic table we're
working with the periodic table as it
was on Wikipedia about 10 years ago so
it's a little bit out of date and so if
you go into the constraints directory
and run Python elements discover 92 pi
what will happen is it will generate a
JSON file call probably elements 92 dot
T to do in fact yes elements 92 dot t--
d da which is a JSON file that contains
constraints that are true of the first
92 ie the elements up to uranium in
periodic table so for those of you who
are not following along I will do it as
well
I probably done it before so I probably
have the files but I'll run it under
school and so that's written elements
ninety two dot T DDA and what that looks
like is this so it's just what it used
us look at the code and see what it
actually what kind of data are used
[Music]
so it read a CSV file in fact using
pandas CSV file reader there's a command
line version of this we can use as well
we'll have a look at that when you
install the TDA library in it installs a
TDD a command which I guess is what we
use to get the examples but there is
also a TD a discover a TDD a verify and
a TDD a detect so this thing anyway is
starting from a CSV file with the
elements and it turning that into a data
frame and then writing out this elements
92 that we're looking at so it's
determined that the atomic number is
positive not it would say non-negative
if it had zeros in it but it's not it's
strictly positive minimum of one maximum
92 that it doesn't have any nulls in it
and it doesn't have any duplicates in it
all of which is pretty much what we
would have said now obviously if we look
at that and we said you know are those
really the appropriate constraints for
atomic number or not atomic number isn't
supposed to camp out at 92 it can
certainly go up to 118 and who knows
what we'll limit really is so we would
probably either want to edit that to
increase it something big like 130 or
under an 18 or whatever we think or take
it off altogether but the point is we've
got a starting point to work from then
we've got the name you can see it's put
in its a string its minimum length is 3
and its maximum length is 3 it's it's
doing this completely stupidly it's just
looking and saying well what is the
shorter string
what is the longer string it's not doing
anything clever until it gets to regular
expressions and we haven't told it to
generate regular expressions because
that's more expensive than the other
parts you have to explicitly tell it to
do that but it doesn't have any Knolls
and that it doesn't have any duplicates
and so we carry them down we've got
various things but what you all see is
you know a lot of them don't have the
duplicates can't the no duplicates
constraint some of them don't have the
nulls constraint it will in case of
fields that only have a single null it
will actually generate a Maps nulls
equals one because that's kind of a
special
case that sometimes you're allowed a
single null in a field as a kind of
catch-all value but not multiple nulls
whether that's appropriate or not I'm
not sure but that's the way the library
works at the moment and so this is just
normally a JSON file you can go in and
edit it
we'll probably even let you do that in
Excel one of these days but we haven't
done it yet so I suspect what we're
supposed to do next is to run a verify
yes oh and so the other thing is you can
see that on here we've also got the
command line version of that so let's do
that if we say TDD a discover and then
we give it our input file which is test
data slash elements ninety two dot CSV
and we tell it where we want the results
to go which will be two elements I'll
just call it elements doc - D - so we
can see it's different that will again
generate that same file hopefully
it didn't generate the same file because
of course Jason isn't ordered so you can
get different orders but if so we could
use the reference test library to filter
out that kind of difference but anyone
we're not going to do that but it's
generated semantically the same an
equivalent file so the next idea is what
happens if we verify that so if we
verify the same data that we built the
constraints on in almost all
circumstances we expect that the
verification should pass because the
software is working correctly we've got
constraints that supposed to be true so
the idea is to make it clear the idea is
that when you run the discover process
usually you should be running at unknown
good data you can write on on data that
includes bad data as well it's just that
then you won't necessarily get all the
constraints you want or you might get
inappropriate constraints and you'll
have to edit them by hand so it's more
setup for running on good data so
there's sort of slightly weird fiction
here is that the good data elements up
to 92 and then these are the weird ones
are coming in and what happens so if we
run a verify which we could either do in
code or again we can do from the command
line with TDD a verify so if we verify
the 408 worth if we first of all verify
the data we built it on with the
constraints that we built then we get 72
constraints pass none fail which is good
but if we run if we run it over the 418
data then we get a bunch of successes
and failures so 57 of the constraints
still pass but 15 of them fail and you
see the ticks and crosses indicate which
ones passed and which ones failed so on
density for example the max check the
max changed which is not surprising some
of these transient elements you would
expect to be denser and there are nulls
because we don't know the density of an
optimum probably
because well it's only stable for like a
fraction of a second so we can get the
summary information like that we can
also something that wasn't true last
year but it's true today is if instead
of verify we say detect then it will
actually and we specify where we want it
to go it will write out the failing
records and by default it just writes
out the interesting it writes out a not
very helpful record number supposed oh
yeah no shouldn't have been that really
okay so maybe that's something we have
to change happily if you say brilliant
if you say - output fields on - per
constraint which in fact you almost
always do
that's almost always true thank you then
we get the same thing but now in bad CSV
we have the failing elements which start
with so mostly this there might be a
little issue that we might have to
address in this new detect functionality
mostly you'll see it starting at 93 94
95 so is the correct ones but we appear
to be writing out one extra record that
shouldn't be failing well that's
embarrassing but anyway that's
conceptually what the detection
functionality does and if it is wrong as
it very much looks like it is we will
get that fixed probably by the end of
the day so that's powerful
is anyone having any problems running
that apart from possibly generating
completely bogus results okay yeah
oh that's fine yeah so the default way
that it runs I think it will report
missing fields but it won't cause things
to fail but I'm fairly sure you can tell
so yeah it's quite it's quite it's quite
flexible in that way and by default it
doesn't care about column order and
stuff like that in fact not just by
default it doesn't care about column
water so it's it matches on name and so
you know if they come at a different
order and stuff like that that's fine
you can't at the moment you would have
to you would have to combine them but
that is obvious I'm in another obvious
thing to be able to do but we haven't
supported we don't yet support is taking
to generating sets of T video files or
more and combining them either by sort
of taking the tightest intersection or
the broadest Union or whatever the I
mean the other the other thing that the
is true is in terms of the way you
actually use this in practice is what
you quite often do you know the ideal
thing is you generate some good data you
generate the crowd restraints correct
constraints the appropriate constraints
and then you use it what you should
obviously do is look at the constraints
that come out and sanity check them and
and then make any adjustments by hand
that seem appropriate if you don't have
time to do that or don't have the
inclination to do that the other thing
that you can do is generate them and
then run your data through it and look
at the ones that fail and that gradually
tells you which ones you might want to
write so in this case for example that
would tell us that the max constraint
isn't appropriate and we might want to
take it out obviously you have to use
judgment about that at that point about
whether to take it out the thing that
you don't get that way is things never
tighten so if you turned out to have bad
data like you had a null in a field
that's not supposed to have nulls and
obviously the null constraint won't get
generated and nothing you do in the
future is going to force that unless you
try regenerating constraints on new
assets of data that maybe have been
cleaned up at which point you might get
tighter constraints and one of the
differences in our commercial version of
software is you explicitly knows about
bad data and it will generate
constraints in a more forgiving way that
says well you know there are only one or
two moles here so I'm actually going to
you know yeah we have got some 10
billion and some - 300 million values
but actually most of the exits between
100 and 200 so we're actually going to
set those as the constraints and in that
case of course you potentially if you
verify the data that we built on you now
actually if you're running it in that
mode where it's allowing bad day so you
potentially it fails when you verify
because it's finding a bad for you we're
not necessarily holding that back out of
out of pure grid we might put that into
the library but it's newer functionality
that we have we tend to test everything
in our in our own software first and
then when we decide it's good and
working perfectly we tend to put it into
the libraries hmm and sometimes give
tutorials a bit too quickly after doing
that so at the bottom of this slide it
says pip install feather format I don't
know people have heard of the feather
format feather is a joint initiative
between where's McKenney
of pandas Fame and Hadley Wycombe of
Hadley verse tidy our our studio Fame to
make a format for writing datasets to
disk that is interoperable between r and
python and the idea with it is that it
also preserves a lot more metadata than
csv files and therefore is better it's
not really designed for long-term
storage but for you know writings on the
out and reading about the next day or an
hour later or later in the same program
or something that kind of thing we have
it's part of the Apache era project it's
quite nice you can pip install further
format to get it I say it's quite nice
it's it's quite nice it doesn't really
work but apart from that it's quite nice
even more than pandas it has a very
flexible approach to types it's pretty
confused about the difference between
ours and empty strings it's pretty
confused about nulls generally actually
I think it basically thinks they
shouldn't exist and by the time you
written out of other file you should
have done a fill na or something and
partly as a result of that we have a
wrapper that turns out we haven't put on
2 pi PPI but which is available from
github called pmmif which has the same
method as feather but saved some extra
metadata that allows things to be saved
to safely and restored more safely into
feather files there nice if you do want
to have you know not going through CSV
files and not just using pickles to
store stuff they're a bit more stable
and a bit more interoperable than those
so we've been using quite a lot in some
of the reference data that we write we
do use feather files for so it'd be
worth installing that and currently
getting from the TDA account on get the
[Music]
the pmmif format for extending that that
it might actually 10 past 10:00 it's
probably not available on pi pi by now
but by this afternoon it will be
available on pi pi as pip install PM oh
I have ok so what do we have now
probably racks PI I'm good guess and
that's an example TDD a file that's
that's failing on one one eight which I
think we did oh here's the brand new
detect functionality that apparently
doesn't work see yes exactly what we've
been doing so detecting is the same as
verification except that it actually
pulls out the failing records so you can
you can use the framework as the kind of
general-purpose anomaly detector if you
like or bad data detector and not just
know overall there's a problem with this
column but actually get the stuff
written out either to a data frame or
asius or or a feather file or a CSV file
again you've got both a command line
version and the non command line the API
version and obviously I'm a bit
embarrassed about that it appears not to
be working but I'm sure it will be
something for everyone I'm sure
we'll get that fixed very shortly and
we'll tweet about it and stuff like that
so we've looked at that absent
constraints yes so inspector Gregory of
Scotland Yard's says to Sherlock am i
coming Sam said I should never tell this
story because no one ever understands it
but I think you'll understand it
inspector Gregory says is there any
other point which you'd wish to draw my
attention talking Sherlock Holmes and
Holmes says to the Curious Incident of
the dog in the night-time and Gregory
says the dog did nothing in the night
time and home says that was the Curious
Incident which of course proved that the
burglar alert or whatever it was was
known to the victim and hence the butler
did it or whatever so when you're
generating these constraints it's very
important not just to look at the
constraints that do get generated and
say are they plausible but to look at
the constraints that don't get generated
so if you run it over a master table
with customer IDs and it doesn't say
that the customer ID mustn't be null
what that's telling you is that there
are nulls in the customer ID field if it
doesn't tell you that the customer ID
has to be unique that's telling you that
there were duplicates in that field and
so as with all cases of looking at data
it's it's very important to be vigilant
and not not do what we always want to do
all the time look at things and convince
ourselves that correct but look at them
and think of all the reasons why they
might be wrong so it will modular bugs
it will produce the correct constraints
for the data that you give it but that
doesn't mean they are the can the
correct constraints for the analytical
problem you're dealing with another
important thing to say is this is not
just about detecting problems with your
input data it's absolutely about setting
problems in your output data and output
and your intermediates as well so you
know if you're generating probabilities
and it's running from like -4 to 13
that's not a great thing either it
probably ought to be kept between I
don't know say 0 and 1
and you know if there's one thing worse
than garbage in garbage out it's gold in
garbage out right you do not want to be
the thing that introduces the problems
into your into your data so do use at
all points in the process this is more
stuff this is about data frames so you
can do this off data frames as well as
off CSV files you can't do it on Jason
yet that's another thing that we might
do a thing that you can do that isn't
talked about in the slides is it will
run directly against data and databases
both for discovery and verifications so
I think we support we definitely support
Postgres and MySQL and sequel Lite and I
think we now support sequel server and
oracle probably and that that list keeps
growing so that's that's powerful as
well you can convert a set of results
itself into a data frame so that you can
end up with data frame that shows you
which constraints past in which
constraints failed which connection
you'll be useful particularly for
reporting and there are lots of things
coming but what I think we'll finish by
doing is talking about reacts by so
there are some contacting oh yeah so I
bought it so if you wanna get in touch
with any of this stuff
those are my details there's blog at t
de edad info the sources on git however
there's a slack channel that you can
ping me and we'll add you to it's a very
very quiet slack channel but it would be
lovely if it became noisy so do do make
it noisy there's it's got its own TVA
account and I've got its own Twitter
account and I've got one of those too
the slides from last year are at the
that URL on the sites from this year
once they've been slightly corrected
will get put up at the 2018 copy of that
this afternoon
probably and finally rax play
Rex pi is part of TDD a if it says
anything about doing them anywhere else
don't do that there's an online version
of Rex pi as well where you can type or
paste in I don't know up to a thousand
or up to ten thousand strings or
something that will generate regular
expressions for them online rocket so
regular expressions
God doesn't matter joke can't believe it
doesn't have the chose you you all know
jamie zawinski thing about you know some
people when it was this signature wasn't
it some people when they see a problem
thing I know I'll use regular
expressions now they have two problems
regular expressions are does everyone
know about regular expressions and I
it's anyone not know regular expressions
fantastic well you all know how easy
they are to write the you know they look
like they say that I don't know why
in fact I'm fairly sure there's a
mistake on this like because various
people have told me that it but they're
sort of right only type things and even
the writings difficult so the idea with
rack Spy is instead of you writing the
regular expression we get the machine to
write the expression there's all jamie
zawinski if anyone doesn't know about it
if you're taking these things into
Python for God's sake use our strings
where which means you don't need nearly
so many back slashes so yes the Pro is
that they're powerful and the cons are
that they're ugly they're hard to write
they're harder to read the harder still
to debug and they're quite hard to
escape if you don't use a string there
was a fad for a while to replace them
with things called verbal expressions
got implemented in about three weeks in
every programming language under the Sun
I've never seen anyone used them since
we all go back to regular and regular
regular expressions so the idea is that
if you to do the work or expired does it
so if when you're generative that lets
do that if when you're generating your
constraints and if you don't have like
paragraphs of text which will then take
lifetime the universe for it to work
through if you say TDD a just some cover
data stop and you say - - wreck
something it will also generate regular
expressions and if we look at I will not
start TDD a so you can see it has
figured out that chemical symbols are a
capital letter followed by a lowercase
letter which is true no it's not
oh no sorry a capital letter followed by
a number of lowercase letters which is
true and it's figured out that chemical
symbols are a capital letter followed by
I know a mixture okay so it's not
perfect but that it's 1 or 2 up to 92
it's 1 or 2 capital and lowercase
letters now ideally it would obviously a
capital letter followed by log its
latter but turns out this is quite
tricky and what else we've got chemical
series it's found three different
patents for chemical series it's it's
not very good
repeated fragments at the moment or
repeated capture groups but it can do
that when it generates them Rex why you
can tell it to put capture groups in for
any of the bits that are not constant so
that you can then pull them out
afterwards resource are quite powerful
outside the context at EDTA so so we can
do this we can also from the command
line just I think yes we can just type
Rex PI and either pipe stuff into it or
put things in sort you know a typical
thing would be to sort of put in you
know kinds of identify as we tend to get
[Music]
and even for simple things like this
that should be enough it will generate
an appropriate or sometimes
inappropriate regular expression in some
cases it doesn't generate a single one
it generates a set of regular
expressions and it will check that at
least one of them is true for each
string and what the results it's
definitely still a work in progress I
mean it doesn't it's it's a bit one of
the things to say about does it's purely
heuristic method it's not it's not got a
quality measure it's not guaranteeing or
even really trying accept sort of
implicitly in the programming to find
the optimal string whatever that would
mean of course the optimal the optimal
expression isn't really well defined you
know in our heads we know that we'd like
it to be the one that captures all the
stuff that's good and excludes all the
stuff that's bad but given that we don't
know the universe of strings that exist
in those two categories it's it's kind
of hard to do that so it's it's
gradually improving over time we're
close to having something to allow us to
do the repeated fragments that I think
will help quite a lot but even now for I
guess the thing to emphasize about it is
what it's really good for is the sort of
categorical strings that you tend to get
that have structure in real data sets
what it is completely hopeless for and
it will take stupid amounts of time if
you feed it is like English sentences
and English paragraphs and stuff like
that where clearly there is no sensible
pattern for it to generate but it will
you know it will carry on trying
stupidly anyway so that's Rex pine how
we doing it's 20 past tense but we're
quite closer I think have a look at the
slides and see whether there's anything
else well that's the online hiraku
version but you can download it and
install it you oh yeah there are sort of
options you can specify so you can help
it a bit by telling it if you've got
identifiers and underscores are really
being tricked like letters it's helpful
to give it a - you and then it will do
that if dots are supposed to be treated
as part
anta fires you can tell it that and same
with minuses you can specify whether you
want it to put the brackets in for
capture groups and one of the other
things that's happened over the last few
months is it's become much better at
handling Unicode so it will now it will
generate rather cryptic regular
expressions but correct regular
expressions even for accented characters
and whether people have come across the
oh and it works in pandas yeah I know
people have the operator in regular
expressions but minus W and in
particular minus capital W so but minus
W
I always thought match the word but it
doesn't it matches an alphabetic
character in the alphabet that you're in
in other words it will cope with accents
on letters as well and underscores
annoyingly which usually you don't want
and digits which usually you don't want
but if you use minus capital W which
means everything that isn't that and
then you reverse it with an up arrow and
a bracket and then you take out
explicitly the digits and the
underscores you actually get a unicode
character and so that's the trick that
it uses when matching unicode letters
about international letters accented
letters which turns out to be very
powerful it just makes rather ugly
regular expressions but it works
remarkably well I think that's me unless
anyone has questions
so I mean in terms of the algorithm the
way it guards against it is it's all
just heuristic anyway so it's you know
it's just trying to do its thing in
general I would say when you're using in
practice what you do is you run it you
see whether it generates something
useful and if it doesn't and you can see
how it's failing you put in an example
that will stop it doing that so if all
your examples start with a 1 then it's
doing a really good thing if it produces
a ones in them but if that's not what
you want
put another you know copy the last
example replace the one with the two and
and now it won't it's not a great answer
but it's it's the only answer of god
yeah well I mean the other thing is
obviously I edit the regular expression
but then you're back into the I mean
it's not magic it's just a heuristic
yeah
that would that wouldn't yes so if
people can't hear the suggestion is
rather than just giving it the positives
the things that you do want to match you
should be able to give it the negatives
as well and we have thought about that
and that's a great idea you could submit
a patch with that and if you don't fancy
doing that I'll add it to the to do list
for later this afternoon
yep that's a good idea any other yes I
think I think you misunderstand the the
consultant client relationship we don't
ask the client for permission to write
tests we write the tests and if they
complain we're taking too long they
explain they don't understand what
they're talking about no I mean there is
more seriously there is I don't think I
know anyone you know I've been
advocating automated testing for at
least 15 years I don't know anyone who
doesn't find it a struggle to do it
I myself if I just want to get something
done tend not to write any tests in the
naive and stupid belief that it will be
faster than that even though I know it
won't be faster like that it will
actually be slower because I'll make
mistakes that will take me longer to fix
I mean my very fun belief is that
writing tests isn't you know it's not
some thrill it's not something that you
only do if if if it's a really important
project it's it's the fastest way to get
code working in general I think and it
is definitely the only way I know to get
results that I have any level of trust
in at all so if a client really said do
it without the tests I mean I would
either refuse to work with that client
or I would write them anyway and just
not include the tests in the
deliverables or something but in
practice we so we do get the pushback
but it's usually not all that hard and
we're sufficiently inflexible about it
that it
waise goes away and we've never actually
had a client said say well you know if
you're going to insist on rain tests
you're not there you're not the
consultants for us do you have the
opposite experience yeah but it should
be but it shouldn't be hard to justify
taking less time for the whole project
because you're spending some of your
time on testing rather than all of your
time on wondering why stuff isn't
working right you just have to believe
it sufficiently strongly the other I
mean the other interesting thing for us
is we our our software mirror our
proprietary software is about 300,000
lines of Python and until very recently
it was three hundred thousand lines of
Python - with utf-8 in the middle rather
than Unicode mostly and as some of you
may have heard come 2020 that's not
going to be a great position to be in so
we've been going through and have
converted it all and I think that would
have been completely impossible for us
to do if we didn't have over a thousand
tests with over 15,000 test cases which
is what we do have for that software
especially given that the the approach
we took was we tried to make it work and
succeeded in making it work the same
source work in Python - with byte
strings in Python - with Unicode
literals and in Python 3 obviously with
the literals but it's it's only because
of the tests we could I mean the you
know when we first when we first started
running it in Python 3 I think like 970
or whatever of the thousand tests
wouldn't pass
I remember the number of test cases but
it was it was absolutely staggering
and and in fact one of the interesting
things was we found about a dozen bugs
in the Python 2 code just from the
purposes of trying it in Python 3 not
that we have a right bugs I would any
other points yep
okay so the question was is there any
support for time-series no there's not
time series or ranges of dates so I
guess the generalized version of that
question would be rather than having a
continuous training or a minimum the max
having a sequence of mints max so there
it's sorry there is support in sense
that you can have date fields and it
will it will handle those appropriately
and I think we haven't put this into the
open source version yet but I might be
wrong in the proprietary version we also
have the concept of relative dates so
dates relative to either today or a
reference day rather than the absolute
date range so that as stuff flows
forward the more it's possible that is
in the library but I don't think so yeah
but it will be it's deafening held back
so the more general thing of course is
you know a sequence of overlapping
ranges which we have for Strings in
effect because you can list a set of
strings or a set of regular expressions
we don't have that at the moment the
other thing you can do of course is and
if a very powerful things to I should
have mentioned this and I'll be talking
about anomaly detection with this
afternoon which uses this library for
source some of what we'll be talking
about is using this night before anomaly
detection a very powerful thing of
course to do is just to write your own
constraints your own urine checks that
build actual columns in the data set
that are either 1 0 columns or anything
that the constraints that it does do
have a sensible effect on and then you
can just feed those in and I mean sure
you're doing the work but you get a nice
integrative framework where the records
that fail your extra checks fail these
as well and in fact the other the other
thing I should have mentioned is another
very useful thing to do is not just to
run tests on a particular data frame but
also on things that you derive from that
data frame like a crosstab that you
produce that you know counts the number
of occurrences and things and so forth
tests on derived artifacts or you know
aggregate data sets or whatever that
come off your data sets all that joined
data sets together or any of those sorts
things again if you have two data sets
and they're supposed to have common join
keys you know join them together and
check for the knowledge you don't have
to do a new thing if there are nozzles
in that provide that you don't outer
join if there are nulls in the key field
in the joint thing then you know that
they were about joint keys and so forth
but the short answer is no but there's
no real support detection it's
[Applause]